I very honored by this distinction that
touches me profoundly my love and
appreciation for motion pictures started
very early in my life I remember when I
was five years old my parents took me to
see a movie a horror movie
another mom I realized that without
music they will be so scared and in
truth I have been fortunate to have the
opportunity to work the great
outstanding directors producers and
talented talented musicians in the
creation of music music as called to
support their projects so you have any
questions yeah
[Applause]
what a spaniel I look at yours
no I I read no no sir he's with my
teachers you know he's generous because
he he's afraid I'm going to compete with
his who him as an actor that work is
doing is about dodging my speech
I like to thank my my father my mother
my teachers my friends my family and
especially my wife
composing for movies composing for
movies has a lifetime of joy and
creativity receiving this honorary Oscar
is a culmination of a dream it is a
mission accomplished
again my always warm is gratitude to all
of you for this honor and my personal
thanks to Clint and Cathy for their part
in this celebration applause oh the
muchas gracias amigos
[Applause]